wir müssen also verhindern dass es zu
einem unkontrollierten beziehungsweise
exponentiellen anstieg weiter kommt und
wir sind bereits in der exponentiellen
phase das sieht man an den täglichen
zahlen
wir sind dem zweiten lok dann eigentlich
viel näher als jedes wahrhaben wollen
wenn wir die entwicklung angst schon
heute auch den bericht des experten die
zahlen sich gerade entwickeln welche
dynamik wenn wir sehen was um uns herum
passiert dann ist es wirklich höchste
zeit vielleicht gar nicht mehr fünf vor
zwölf sondern schlag 12 um jetzt die
weichen richtig zu stellen
wir sind einem zweiten lockdown näher
als wir ahnen macht uns das angst
ich glaube die unsicherheit macht angst
macht mehr angst als der zustand selber
heute genau welche die grundsätzliche
situation glaube ich ja so viele gestern
vor also auch die pressekonferenz
verfolgt in den späten abendstunden ja
und ich finde man merkt auch an der pk
das eigentlich jedes wort auf die
goldwaage gelegt wird und gelegt werden
muss weil ich auch merke sozusagen als
zuschauer wie ich darauf reagiere wenn
beispielsweise söder sagt das ist zwölf
ja- und deswegen glaube ich dass dieser
alarmismus uns genauso wenig weiter
bringt wie die verharmlosung und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen das ist der
kanzlerin aber auch dem ganzen team
gestern eigentlich sehr gut gelungen und
ich glaube es ist auch sehr wichtig weil
wir diese mentale krise diesem
kollektiven börner und den dürfen wir
nicht unterschätzen und zwar völlig
unabhängig davon wie viel power wir
haben ob wir nach vorne gehen oder nicht
ich finde gerade die power haben haben
jetzt auch eine ganz besondere
solidarische verantwortung andere an die
hand zu nehmen und was mir so ein
bisschen sorge macht das in der tat dass
wir ganze teile der gesellschaft gerade
verlieren die nämlich überhaupt noch
nicht mal zu wort kommen und die
unsichtbar werden und insofern wird das
jetzt eine herausforderung in den
nächsten wochen und es geht darum dass
wir natürlich auch freiheits
einschränkungen erfahren aber dass sie
eben auch einen guten grund haben und
dass wir dieses infektionsrisiko
eindämmen müssen insbesondere wie es
auch gestern geschildert wurde
wenn man das vergleicht weltweit was da
los ist also schweden wird ja mal
herangezogen als positivbeispiel aber
dass in deutschland nur doppelt so viele
gestorben sind obwohl wir achtfach von
der bevölkerung ehren doch so viele sind
zeigt ja dass wir doch schon vieles
ziemlich richtig machen
verena du nix ich nicke zu kollektiven
burnout denn wenn eltern jetzt zu gucken
dann werden sie genau das gefühl haben
wir haben uns ja noch gar nicht erholt
vom lockdown der bis zum sommer ferien
ging
und wenn es jetzt wieder los ging und
wir die kinder wieder zu hause hätten
dann geht es alles wieder so los wie es
im märz und april war und auch gerade in
den familien wo es gar keine geräte gibt
kein drucker kein schnelles internet wo
die eltern vielleicht gar nicht in der
lage sind zu helfen
da ist nichts besser jetzt und jetzt ist
aber auch noch november oder
oktober/november draußen ist kalt also
das macht angst und ich glaube
kollektiver burnout trifft es wenn man
allen eltern von kindern und
schulkindern ist
ich möchte einmal kurz widersprechen für
denn ich finde also tatsächlich und ich
habe auch vieles positiv gesehen wie
düsen und gesagt hat wir können
eigentlich stolz auf seine mini krise
umgehen ich finde das was gestern wieder
klar wurde ist dass wir tatsächlich ein
flickenteppich sind dass wir überhaupt
so ein sperriges wort wie beherbergungs
verbot haben dass sich unterm strich als
gar nicht wirksam oder irgendwie auch
quatsch oder ist es jetzt was man weiß
es nicht auf jeden fall sind die
länderchefs sich darin nicht einig warum
kamen wir überhaupt auf die idee warum
reden wir über das söder und laschet
sich eigentlich die ganze zeit streiten
also bei mir blieb in dieser
pressekonferenz hängen er das gefühl so
ich weiß nicht ob wir wirklich ein
konzept haben und ich befürchte dass das
bei ganz vielen zu einem
vertrauensverlust führt und ich möchte
dass das damit den menschen futter gibt
wie zum beispiel sagen der maske ist
quatsch da mache ich nicht mit oder ist
doch eh alles gelogen
ich habe das gefühl sie nicht mehr an
einem strang und ich finde da gehört
auch ganz klar dazu zu sagen dass man
angst hat davor das wurde ja auch gerade
gesagt
mir macht es ihre sorge ich denke wir
können weihnachten dieses jahr total
vergessen es wird kein weihnachten geben
so wie wir es kannten mit 1000 besuch
von verwandtschaft mit freunden treffen
mit irgendwo mal in der bar in 1 märkte
oder wie wir sagen es nicht dass wir das
aber aber ich möchte noch mal an die
selbstwirksamkeit erinnern das ist jetzt
der alarmismus des gerade beschrieben
habe zumindest in teilen
also ich möchte dir noch nicht mal
widersprechen dass das jetzt irgendwie
alles toll war gestern in gottes willen
wir sind in der krise und da ist
sozusagen immer im ermessensspielraum
aber es geht letztlich darum und ich
find s hat die kanzlerin sehr schön auf
den punkt gebracht um unsere
selbstwirksamkeit dass wir nicht
machtlos sind und ich glaube das was
menschen wirklich fertig macht wenn man
das gefühl hat dass man nichts daran
ändern kann
aber sie können ja was daran ändern und
auf diese selbstwirksamkeit auch aus
psychologischen gründen jetzt zu setzen
auch mit einem ordentlichen lieder
schritt mit entsprechenden ansprachen
vielleicht auch wieder mit kampagnen wie
am anfang
ich glaube das ist jetzt wichtiger denn
je denn ich denke an die ganzen
kinderaugen die dann eben sagen oh gott
oh gott weihnachten fällt aus dieses
jahr das ist ja unbegreiflich aber es
hat er gestern zum beispiel auch ein
fdp-politiker getwittert was was
überhaupt nicht zur debatte stand also
das fand ich eher so ein bisschen
befremdlich wo ich dachte das ist dieser
teil des alarmismus sehen wir jetzt
gerade eben nicht drauf und das heißt
nicht dass ich das beherbergungs verbot
irgendwie uneingeschränkt teile aber
fühlt ihr euch gut an die hand genommen
also ich
hat er gestern so ein bisschen dass das
gefühl dass das ich da sitze um eine pk
anschaue wie zum ersten mal stattfindet
aber dieses thema ist ja nun monatelang
schon in der gesellschaft jeden tag und
es gibt studien und was weiß ich alles
und ich dachte so ein bisschen aber
jetzt sind wir genau da wo wir im
frühjahr waren was haben wir denn in der
ganzen zeit gemacht was haben wir denn
gelernt
ja und ich glaube dass die menschen
brauchen jetzt klarheit wir werden
10.000 neuinfektionen haben werden wir
haben so und wenn wir die haben machen
wir dann die schulen zu machen wir nicht
wie handhaben wir das dann wenn wir sie
nicht zu machen und besonders schwierig
wenn ich da kurz unterbrechen darf ist
er vor wenigen wochen wurde er noch
gesagt dass wir da auf keinen fall noch
einen zweiten lok da und geben und dann
jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon beim
zweiten block down angekommen das aber
dank meines körpers lockdown leid und es
gab dennoch nicht meinen richtigen
locken aber wir sehen kurz davor dass
man darüber spricht denn wir uns jetzt
nicht zusammenreißen dein wille ist
eventuell noch ein geben und da ist es
natürlich so ein bisschen habermann hat
er vor ein paar wochen gesagt es wird
kein zweiter geben wir dachten wenn auf
so einem guten weg man wird so ein
bisschen emotional zurückgeworfen finde
ich genau und was mir helfen würde als
bürger bürgern ist szenarien also wenn
es zu der infektions höhe kommt dann
werden wir die kinder als erstes nach
hause schicken die zu hause betreut sind
und dort gerät haben sie aber auf die
schule bezieht die anderen dürfen in der
schule bleiben denn das wollen wir nicht
wiederholen dass die fast and lernen zu
hause weil sie gar nicht mitkommen und
dass man so ein bisschen sagt entweder
gibt es da lang oder da aber man
zeichnet die wege schon mal auf und so
habe ich das gefühl wir reagieren jeden
tag auf das was gerade da sind
strukturelle die kanzlerin gestern wenn
sie heute noch einmal betont dass ich
habe es sehr schön dass es darum geht
dass die schulen nicht geschlossen
werden dürften und den hat sie mir
absolute priorität eingeräumt
und lasst uns die maßnahmen
konkretisieren das bezieht sich wirklich
auf die sperrstunde
es bezieht sich auf das feiervolk ist
bezieht sich auf den alkoholkonsum es
gibt also wirklich um eine bestimmte
gruppe die zu der vermehrung des virus
beigetragen hat um das einzudämmen und
zu deiner gruppe so grundsätzlich in
frage
dieses treffen kam er zustande weil das
infektionsgeschehen wieder über maße
genommen hat die jetzt sozusagen
regional punktuell bekämpft werden und
die schule sondern davon profitieren ja
ja absolut also die rede auch gar nicht
wir reden auch nachher nochmaligen hin
bisschen konzentrierter über
homeschooling erzählt wie das eventuell
aussehen würde
das haben wir uns gleich nochmal oder
den ausgleich noch einmal beschäftigen
aber mir geht es einfach darum dass ich
gestern das gefühl hatte als ich die pkk
gesehen habe
das ist tatsächlich dass wir kurz oder
das ist schon zwölf uhr irgendwie so
dass schon gesagt hat dass wir jetzt
wirklich gut zu einem kompletten locker
und wieder stehen und dann denkt man
sich schon so haas was ich denn jetzt in
den letzten monaten passiert weil was
ist los wie wie kann das sein ich glaube
ich glaube also ich glaube es ist jetzt
so richtig ein ich glaube dass wir
tatsächlich kurz von einem lok 1000
stehen
ich glaube auch nicht dass man auch wenn
unser gesundheitsminister das gesagt hat
dem 100 prozent glauben schenken kann
dass die schulen alle offen bleiben es
werden ja auf jeden fall teilweise
klassen nicht gemacht wir brauchen ein
krankes kind und schon stecken eltern
wieder im homeschooling für zwei wochen
weil die ganze klasse nach hause gehen
muss also die schulen werden immer
wieder betroffen sein
und ich glaube dass eben weil du gerade
auch von dem führungsstil spaß ich
glaube es ihm ganz viel durch diesen
flickenteppich durch die länderchefs die
ausscheren durch das linzer eines raumes
föderalismus namensschilder realismus
die ereignisse kinder ermitteln und
sagen wir haben hier ja keine zahlen und
das eben fehlt und dass auch was verena
sagte dass eben fehlt ist wir sagen okay
es gibt szenarien a b c d e und so wird
das ablaufen und so wird das für uns
alle ablaufen und er die die weniger
betroffen sind werden trotzdem eine
maske tragen warum damit sie in zukunft
nicht stark betroffen sind und das ist
der punkt der bei mir und das war
gestern mit dieser pk zum ersten mal so
der kam für mich nicht mehr klar rüber
und erfahrung für mich auch nicht mehr
vertrauenswürdig aber ich hatte das
gefühl so merkel möchte einen plan
machen und die länderchefs machen was
sie wollen nicht aber genau so war es ja
auch genau und das war ja dass ich das
gefühl hatte sondern ich glaube schon
dass auch eine besondere krise in der
bundeseinheitliche regelung verlangt die
im zoo der realismus sonst nicht möglich
ist wird aber genau so viele leute da
draußen geben die mich jetzt in dem
moment wieder sprechen und sagen würden
stoppt beschränkt meine freiheitsrechte
ein im übrigen auch meinem eines
bundeslandes also insofern hat das
natürlich beide sind ja wohl sascha jahr
sind sieben landtagswahlen glaube ich
und eine bundestagswahl also man will
jetzt natürlich auch format gewinnen und
nur der kanzlerin hinterher zu laufen
ist vielleicht für manche nicht das
format haben wollen und jetzt übrig und
jetzt wird es noch einmal spannend jetzt
wird es spannend
darum geht es ja letztlich maler und
nichtleben auch dass du hast natürlich
recht dass so eine krise nicht nur
verliert man dafür nicht benötigt da hat
dass sie dafür nicht benutzt werden darf
und dass ich schon auch das den menschen
zutrauen dass auch unterscheiden zu
können deswegen glaube ich auch jemand
der nichts zu verlieren hat und dann
würde ich die kanzlerin einfach mal so
einordnen
der geht es wirklich um die sache ohne
es anderen absprechen zu wollen um
gottes willen die diskussions fähigkeit
ist ja das was uns in der demokratie
immer auch smart aber wir müssen
wirklich jetzt ganz genau hingucken was
da eben auch passiert und da sind die
menschen zu recht sehr empfindlich denn
es hat ja unmittelbare auswirkungen
finanzieller existenzieller
gesundheitlicher natur aber haben uns
sicherer gefühlt als am anfang
der pandemie war es ja schon so dass
frau merkel sehr regelmäßig zu uns
gesprochen hat als volk und na also
wir fühlten uns mitgenommen wir fühlten
uns irgendwie das dass sie auf uns
aufpassen die motive sagen und hat uns
das vielleicht ein bisschen stärker
gemacht hat uns das ein bisschen mehr
vertrauen gegeben also ich persönlich
mir schon ja bei mir sind jetzt gerade
zu viele meinungen überall in der
politik und man weiß gar nicht was was
was ist überhaupt mir fehlt so eine die
zwar auf den tisch haut sagt jetzt
reicht's aber so und so sieht aber genau
das wird sie nie machen und das macht
sie trotzdem so stark und das ist
leadership und sie ich sage es nochmal
sie setzt auf die selbstwirksamkeit und
die solidarität in der gesellschaft
machte gesundheitsminister übrigens auch
es geht darum uns daran zu erinnern dass
wir den unterschied machen können und zu
appellieren und mit dieser vernunft mit
relativ wenigen verboten sind wir bisher
ja total toll sehr weit gekommen
das heißt es gibt ja auch in einem grund
er sage ich mal weiter zu machen und
trotzdem was nicht zu verharmlosen aber
eben trotzdem nicht in diese angst modus
zu fallen dass wir uns abhängig machen
von von von menschen die uns jetzt sagen
wie es geht denn das rätsel gibt es
nicht und ich kann mich ehrlicherweise
auch in keinen politiker den letzten
monaten erinnern der gesagt hat dass
wird kommt das wird nicht kommen sondern
wir erleben ja das gegenteil wir können
euch nicht sagen was passiert ja aber
trotzdem hatte man so ein bisschen aber
ich hatte mir ein bisschen klarere
einschätzung erhofft aber vielleicht ist
es auch war das zuviel märchen
[Musik]